[Music]
yeah you can see that uh something has
came down through here all this lyan's
all rubbed off could be probably more
than likely an old slide maybe a bear
come down through here never know not
seeing any tracks or signs so I don't
think anything's real fresh but they are
using
this it is hunting season we have a very
long deer season on the island which is
a blessing we don't have moose on this
island we don't have really anything
else besides Blacktail
deer earlier in the spring I did see a
lot of game tra trails and tracks and it
looks like it could be at some time very
[Music]
profitable
I know this call works good for for bear
for sure um in the spring when The Fawns
are dropping you can tighten these
bands make a fwn call and then Bears
will be lying right for you they'll run
you smooth
over looking for that Fawn it's uh so so
far it's worked on Bears hopefully
she'll get get a deer in here
we do have a predator issue on this
island in the spring those black bear
when The Fawns start dropping their only
thing is eating fawns and the Wolves
their only thing is eating these
Blacktail
deer our deer population is
dwindling it it really hammers our
chance to feed our family when the
Predator pop population is so high that
you're not seeing the
deer wind's really kicking up I see
these conked up him loocks here means
they're really rotten and they're
starting to rock and
[Music]
roll you got to watch too grabbing these
little rotten ones you shake them and
that that top just wobbles sucker will
come off there and whack you right in a
bean when I first came up logging a
buddy of mine he was cutting and that
you can see there's a rotten limb that
had already broke off there and right
above that big sweeper that comes out he
was cutting on it and started pounding
wedges well it was rotten like that
bottom one and that whole sweeper come
off and crushed him killed him
killed him on
site I do miss logging I do miss
cutting but it is nice to know every day
I'm home with the kids and I'm not
coming home in the Box
either happens to a lot of
[Music]
us